[Music]
neither sequels nor remakes pokemon
ultra son and ultra moon taking a mostly
simple approach to updating 2016's sun
and moon much of the previous games has
been left untouched the story once again
takes place on the tropical island
region of a lola and focuses on the
island challenge which differs slightly
from the series typical gym badge based
progression but some key story details
have changed keeping things surprising
for returning players even if the story
itself is basic RPG fare most notably
there are small quality of life
improvements in charming touches that
make an already enjoyable Pokemon game a
more endearing experience regardless of
your skill level
the original Sun and Moon brought a new
pokemon a break from the gym formula and
a number of updates that make the
seventh generation ultra Sun and Moon
included the most approachable and
prettiest pokemon games yet with an
overwhelming roster of monsters to catch
Sun and moons UI improvements made it
easier to battle without an encyclopedic
knowledge of every Pokemon as well as
train your prize fighters for the
competitive meta game but if you fell
somewhere between beginner and meta
player a mediocre story and pacing
issues may have been disappointing Ultra
Sun and Moon immediately streamlined the
originals especially slow start as a
newcomer to a Lola you quickly get your
first Pokemon and are initiated into the
island challenge a series of trials that
alone in Pokemon trainers undergo to
prove themselves instead of meeting all
the characters and going through a few
cutscenes before picking your starter
Pokemon this time around you get to pick
a starter right away and then go through
the introductory story beads the result
is an opening that doesn't hold your
hand in the same way it did before
though it still has the obligatory
Pokemon catching tutorial among others
and lets you wander more freely a
welcome change for both returning and
new players
[Music]
some of the trials are a bit different
this time like the one where you have to
find a series of ingredients to make a
stew which adds a more puzzle-like
element to stave off the fetch quest
feel most notably though the battles
against the powerful totem Pokemon seem
a bit more sophisticated the ally
Pokemon that joined these extra powerful
opponents in battle will sometimes use
doubles support moves like sunny day to
throw a wrench in your plans and the
added challenge is more satisfying to
overcome
[Music]
other than the trial tweaks the next 15
or so hours are essentially the same as
Sun and Moon but new small details
breakup stretches of repetition your
Rotom pokedex asks you questions and
makes adorable faces as you get to know
it though it can be a little too chatty
at times you'll occasionally find a
Pokemon in the world that just wants to
play with you and you can do things like
play peekaboo and even walk through a
meadow of playful Pikachu
talking to everyone too has its benefits
there are tons of new silly and cute
interactions to be had that add even
more personality to a Lola and its
inhabitants while all the best parts of
Sun and Moon are present and accounted
for and things in general get off to a
quicker start ultra Sun and moons story
remains underwhelming and with the
introduction of a new sort of antagonist
in the robotic mysterious ultra recon
squad duo there's almost too much going
on especially since there's already two
antagonist groups in oh Lola as is by
the time you've confronted team skull
and are immediately thrown into a
confrontation at the returning aether
paradise you'll probably wish you could
just get back to your island challenge
and become the champion already
[Music]
though they aren't very different from
their predecessors ultrasonic ultramoon
make enough changes to stand apart as
the definitive versions of the seventh
generation games an overly complicated
story is offset by charming details that
bring even more life to the most vibrant
pokemon region to date and small fixes
iron out the shaky er parts of the
original journey if you make it through
a Lola a second or even first time
you'll be rewarded with a fun-filled and
uplifting Pokemon adventure with its own
share of spoilers surprises in store
[Music]
you